right well hello everyone we are going
to get the lightning talk started i have
some of my lightning talkers and i will
round them up going along the first
lightning talks we have for you will be
from alex and valerio they're going to
be giving a shout out to euro python and
euro scipy i'm telling you all about
that coming up and of course they'll be
after at the end of the lightning talk
if you yourself are running a meetup or
a conference series and you are
restarting uh now that the the world is
returning to a new normal uh then you
are very welcome uh to stand up and
announce your meet up uh and your
community that you are trying to start
right without further ado chaps you have
five minutes so all right
thank you very much
all right
so the first lightning talk so we just
want to introduce a little bit to
southwest germany that's pi datas at
west
that's southwest germany so we're here
it's a combination of three soon four
cities uh we've gathered one meet up
here and this is basically how the
community there looks like
and
uh yeah and we have this one event i
want to tell you about uh but
remember we're in southwest germany um
you know and then focus is in austin
texas yeah keep that in mind so this is
how we imagine texas in germany
and if you google austin actually it
seems to look more like this
so um
last year we
planned uh um
our next event so i was talking to jim
say hey we're going to go back and have
the new meetup and you should know about
texas and austin they are really proud
of barbecue so basically texas ribs bbq
everything's texas barbecue and i said
hey jim we have this new uh the meat of
the big data barbecue is coming back
again
and then jim just said oh big data bbq
that's awesome why didn't he come up
with this here in texas so actually the
claim now is a big data bbq uh it's
actually made in germany and we have to
bring it back to texas again
that said um i'm really happy to
announce um the next big beta bbq with
pi ladies all female speakers just
coming 7th of july so if you're in the
area if you're around if your friends
please have them come by we're really
happy it's like 200 people barbecue cool
talks networking and talking about
food of course it's barbecue but we also
have vegetable options like veggie
options so uh of course it includes
basil and
very also yeah so talking about
basil
how about having a conference in basel
this time switzerland um that was a good
joke i told you
oh yeah
oh my god i don't deserve collapse for
this but yeah so um we're gonna have you
sci-fi back again um
after after two years of stop uh it's
going to be in switzerland uh we had the
call for proposal open unfortunately
it's closed now so it was open um
and it's going to be end of august 29th
of august 2nd of september this year
location is switzerland again uh we're
gonna have a kind of a hybrid conference
in person and remote if you can't attend
it uh we're gonna have our tutorials and
so the structure of your supply we're
gonna have two uh two days of uh
tutorials two days of talks and the last
day is sprints for open source project
this is the usual structure you use high
pi it's about uh you python and science
well you can you can find very very i'm
sure lots of contributions from from
this audience uh ticket sites will be
open soon presumably in one week it's
just like a matter of fixing things with
the swiss government uh please check out
the website here's our bid slash 2022 on
twitter at eurosci pi and i go and go
back to alex thanks oh so we started
with the quiz so oh yeah so now i get
james attention um
what have the james webb space telescope
the jill killer robots and ai dystopian
common
three two one other solutions actually
you're a python because we have great
keynotes about everything so we have
patrick here he's working on a james
webb space telescope and he's going to
give a keynote just
one day after nasa will release the
first pictures from this new space
telescope which is basically the
replacement for hubble so we're really
excited laura from slack she will talk
about killer robots and her work at
google and i'm also like super thrilled
um sam gross from facebook ai will come
about because actually he removed the
jill um in a fork and this is like
really changing thing for python in the
future really the because many people
tried this before and we have nakima and
she will also talk about ai dystopia and
i work at phone loops so you person is
close by
um it's in dublin it's uh in in july um
we're really happy uh if you want to
come by programs up ticket sales up just
visit the website check out the program
we also have a
great pie data talk and i have one more
minute and i have nothing left to say
yeah that ladies and gentlemen how you
do a lightning talk if you live yourself
50 seconds at the end that's good we
appreciate it right this is our small
little impromptu segment uh does anyone
here organize a meetup or a conference
or things like that and they'd like to
tell everyone in the room they're doing
it
i see a hand at the back
[Music]
there we go we planted a stooge uh that
is of course john uh co-organizer of the
conference
so yes the pioneer london meetup has
restarted it will be oh excellent
uh we're still cool
[Laughter]
fantastic anyone else who would like to
get excellent
one just restarted when omicron
died off basically and we're having our
next meet up on thursday so it happens
to be around in madrid
lovely there we go fantastic
right
anybody else
john you can't go again mate
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry there's a hand over here
[Music]
is that something they can find on
meetup.com or something like that
bath machine learning meetup
fantastic if you're in the ancient city
of aqua less you can of course go along
to a machine only meet up fantastic
rights
jim
you heard alexander talk about austin
barbecue and thought that sounds pretty
good uh october 27 28 we're doing uh
python at scale conference in austin
texas
there we go so lots of events suddenly
coming out of the woodwork it's good
isn't it right
dina you're next mates we're going to
have our next lightning talk speed up so
dean is going to talk on
just data oh data marketplaces it just
says data
that's really broad mate you've got five
minutes
how do i switch it hey
i'm going to talk talk about data
marketplaces right so
you know in theory data is
you know everyone talks about
acquiring data sets but in practice you
know it's really hard to find
data sets to buy
or samples
once you sort of even identify data sets
which are for sale
then sort of
speaking to a broker sales team getting
getting it credentialed
uh
large data vendors won't sort of just
allow you to use your credit cards and
buy data so it's pretty hard to do it in
practice
and once you have access to a data set
then you have to wait for your it team
to etl it across
and then eventually you can end up using
it and once you sort of even set up a
pipeline every update you know follows
the same cycle or the reduced cycle
again if you're a data producer or you
have valuable data assets it's pretty
hard for a small company to monetize it
its assets
it's not easy to list it
if even if you list it it's hard to sort
of spend uh in yeah money on it
infrastructure to sort of publish data
sets
so this this is the state of the art in
data sharing right a lot of
your data producers or
you know data companies like uh market
data providers do this right so so they
extract data from their data warehouses
or data lakes
put it on onto sftp sites
when you have large data sets you have
to chunk it up
and then there's a huge process on the
other side which does it in reverse and
it takes months especially if you have
large data sets
and this is pretty expensive right so
sftp servers
use
expensive disk have to be kept running
24 7.
so that's the state of the art it takes
months it's pretty expensive and it's
hard to sort of do it at
scale so things are pretty much changing
with
data marketplaces right so this thing's
going away and it's been sort of
uh
a lot of cloud vendors allow you to sort
of publish data to your shared buckets
and
instantly
access is given to the
consumer buckets in an instant so what's
changing from sftp is all these data
exchanges allow you to sort of
put data in the cloud and they just
provision access to each of your
consumers
and along with it it comes with
cataloging
tools to provision access
and your consumers can run workloads
immediately this is a view of what
snowflake does so effectively if you
publish to your snowflake account all
your consumers get access to data
instantly but pretty much the most other
most of the cloud vendors have something
similar
and most exchanges would have these
features out of the box right so you can
have a catalog where you can list your
assets for sale you have samples you
have documentation
you have scalable storage which is
pretty cheap uh you you don't need
service learning 24 7 and you just have
one copy of data
uh you have an entitlements uh
system which allows you to sort of
entitle only people who have bought data
you have some exchanges also sort of
manage billing and fulfillment for you
and then your clients or consumers can
run analytics in place so with snowflake
or aws the moment you publish data it
comes in all your consumers
sc buckets or their
databases and pretty much within seconds
the analyst can run it in place
so
yeah so these exchanges allow you to
allow
publishers to sort of publish data and
sell it
effectively reach more customers because
you have it listed in the catalog
and it's valuable to customers pay more
because they have zero etl cost
on their side
and you get rid of a lot of i.t and
fulfillment teams
that are currently involved in
monetizing things
a cool feature with these assets is you
can actually have views on assets right
so you can sort of
join
or filter data sets
and limit
what you
publish
or customize it as well per customer
in addition you know it's a cheap way of
even if you are not selling data within
organizations it's a cheap way of
building a data mesh because it comes
with a catalog you can share
assets across business lines uh and you
don't need to sort of spend a lot of
time on infrastructure building a data
measure it's like a ready-made data mesh
where a lot of data lakes are moving to
so that's all i had
very well done did you have 12 seconds
left on the clock perfect thank you very
much for that and data and marketplaces
our next lightning speaker arturo
is there an arturo
yes mates
if you want to come and do you have
you got a memory stick good right who's
got a laptop uh
yeah that's a problem
judy can i borrow a laptop cheers yes
please
lovely and arturo is going to talk about
psychic learn mooc and let's see if i
can do my acronyms
massive oh where is it online
nope
nope
oh no it's educational
it should work
is it being recognized
yeah that's it
[Music]
they are perfect
all right talk to you five minutes is
yours big round of applause everyone
okay i don't know how to use this to set
the full screen
window probably
view
let's say the interval screen sure or
slideshow
perfect
okay anyway i'm going to be relatively
brief um
so i'm here to present you the mooc
machine learning invited in python with
scikit-learn mooc stands for multi-open
online course which is yeah
open
and yes
this is
are working
in collaboration with both the core
developers of scikit-learn or at least a
subset of us
uh in riyadh in particular in real life
learning lab which is a french
institution
and also the francium american
university numerique which is uh the
platform we are using to have the
the quizzes uh running for getting a
scores and certificate but i'm going to
get in more into details right now so as
i was saying we have a forum and it's
moderated by some of the core developers
of scikit-learn so we it's a very active
forum
very friendly and it usually goes beyond
the material that is covering the course
so i strongly recommend taking this
course just because of the first bullet
point
so
it's also very useful for
people who are starting to get
involved with machine learning because
you have nothing to install
you also get free certification
and something that really makes us
different from everybody else else is
that we are open source which means you
can
literally contribute to
to the course so if you see some of the
content which is not very well explained
or that you think that it can be
improved
uh you can send a pr and we will take it
into account you can also take a look at
the issues in our github which is a that
one in the bottom
and make some comments or address some
issues
and we also have this static version of
the mooc which is which is open and
available all the time and you can
i mean we have a screenshot here
uh which corresponds to the
to the static version in the jupiter
book but as i was saying we also have
the the phone version which is not
running running in the moment
but is the one that
allows for certification
so
our philosophy is to have the hands-on
like
coding and
beyond
answering just questions and
a good
mix between
the concepts and actual work
so we have 15 video lessons 70
programming notebooks 21 exercises which
are not graded
so it's really a lot of work so it's
supposed to be
achievable in seven weeks
but everybody can do it on their own
pace
we are we are usually open for
periods of two months
so far we have had two sessions one last
year and one this year
from
february to
may and we are planning to have a third
session on
the fall of this year probably october
november we still don't have a fixed
date
so
[Music]
the structure of the course is like this
it really goes step by step
to introduce people into machine
learning
and
it's not the usual structure that a mooc
may have because we want people to
really get to make a model as a very
simple model from the very first
notebook so you you get a
taste of a data set and then you start
cutting simple stuff
also it's really good when you are
trying to understand how the
scikit-learn library works because from
the very first module you
get to build a pipeline and
understand how to
join different processes for instance
pre-processing of categorical versus
numerical variables and then
how to ensemble this
in a in a pipeline
perfect
at the end we we have a bunch of
positive comments so it's not only me
who thinks that the mooc is very well
done
we have a a lot of friendly users in
general in in our community and most of
the people are
really interested in going beyond and in
fact in the conclusion model we give
some tips on how to contribute and how
to go beyond the contents of the mooc
so
many thanks this is the team this is the
subset of uh core developers that are
working uh
in the project and uh the technical comm
well the technical part of
the pedagogical team
so that's it thanks
right thank you very much so our next
one if we can have the stage larry
i saw him earlier larry dong
here we are hello mates
got a laptop so this one comes off
that's yours thank you thanks
right
and larry is going to talk on the value
of an open source community to a phd
student how many phd ex-phd students do
we have in the room
there we go you're a good company my
friends oh that's great there's a bunch
of us who've done it lovely uh are you
already larry screen
no i'm plugged in oh wait a second
that's the power cable ah oops
yeah well it's a better one i think
some cookie crumbs stuck in there
okay one moment
there we are
five minutes big round of applause
all right so thanks everyone for having
me um my name is larry i'm a second year
phd student in biostatistics at the
university of toronto all the way from
canada
and you can hear some of my social media
links for a bit of advertisement but you
can also read more about my experience
on my website
so i'd like to start off the talk by
sharing a little bit about the burnside
analogy so german batches and masters i
primarily study in a building called
burnside
and it kind of looks like a minecraft
dungeon it's okay
it's it's not so appealing but inside
there is a very vibrant community i
started my phd in september 2020 the
height of the
global pandemic as we all know and uh
yeah it was it was quite tough like
let's not sugarcoat it but this unique
experience has
showed something i guess something very
interesting is that well it was a bit
lonely because we lacked in-person
communication but there was an
environment that thrived in an online
format
right we're at pi data so it is open
source so my journey to open source was
i guess sort of unexpected as i entered
the phd program right i was entering a
phd program i was going to do research i
guess but maybe a little bit of history
here so i started using prime c3 back in
february 2019 so pimc now
is a probabilistic programming framework
chris gave a very nice tutorial
yesterday and this can warrant another
full hour and a half
uh and in july 2020 there is a summer
school on dirichlet processes so
directly processes can also warrant few
weeks of course
and it's a family of non-parametric
methods for the estimation of density so
i won't get into that
in detail but it's also a work in
progress when i started my phd there is
a bit of interest in knowing what
bayesian package i should use well now i
answered my own question
um but it really only started in april
2021 when there was a tweet for gsoc
gsoc is google summer of code and was a
really nice
springboard into contributing to open
source and my project was to implement
the sub module for dirichlet processes
once again it warned of much more
conversation about this but
all i want to say is until now i'm still
contributing to pymc there was we had a
major version brump and i was trying to
help out as much as i could i'm trying
to dive deeper dive deeper into its back
ends
and i guess the summary of the talk
today would um if would be twofold i
guess for phd students or just students
in general
and to open source maintainers so i
guess the first question is like why why
a student should we get involved and
because at the end of the day for phd we
want to write a 100 page plus
dissertation and that's why we want to
graduate um but there's a few
i guess appealing uh aspects of going
getting involved in open source first of
all you can learn very well in my
opinion there's a lot of these things
that for me was a steep learning curve
in the beginning learning how to just
get use git branching pull requests
issues and whatnot object-oriented
programming unit testing for me
probabilistic programming and to get to
know the whole ecosystem of tools that
are already available was something that
was very appealing
and there are tangible goals and you can
gain a lot of momentum and to learn
via small issues i think in graduate
studies research inherently is very
difficult progress can seem slow but
these issues can be very motivating and
and once again you can have a lot of
learning and i think another two
more appealing
aspects there's a nice network of
professionals outside of academia for
myself i've been studying i guess quite
a lot
in the past few years but to get to know
people who have been through the same
shoes and we had a few hands-raised
people who've been through a phd
program there's a nice network of people
that you can maybe connect with that or
won't say you should do research for the
rest of your life
and uh and yeah open source opens doors
and commute and
allows you to have access to a lot of
these communities that are very
welcoming like the one i'm i'm part of
and very i'm very grateful and and and
you know it is also very attractive in
the sense that it is stepping stone into
software development which is
a very financially financially appealing
skill to have
uh less
and uh if if i encapsulate all this into
a single um single message for students
phd students masters or whatever you're
studying don't be shy you know the we do
have a lot of communities online
available who are ready to to welcome
you and find a project
that you're passionate in and ask
questions you know a lot of people are
ready to help for prime see we have a
discourse and we're always trying to
engage with new users and experienced
users and whatnot
lastly
to open source maintainers if i had just
maybe a few things to share with you
your project can positively impact
students my focus right of this talk is
i guess my experience but just students
in general and your community can bring
students together people who are looking
for professional and personal
development you know at the end of the
day our studies are our challenges can
be inherently similar and you might you
may have a lot more to offer to students
more than more than you think and
and graduate students of course or
students in general well we
our studies will come to an end at some
point right so we'll be looking for jobs
that's it thanks for listening guys
you very much larry and of course best
of luck defending your viva it's a
terrifying experience
um
there's no other way of putting it it's
absolutely terrifying um
right uh juan mark alkezy nope two ones
this one
man i love it when the puns just throw
themselves together um yes if you'd like
to set yourself up on the lecten
um
one mark alkezy will be telling us
that's why i'm getting it wrong i think
it's a podium
ah podium not a lectern
because you have to stand up you're not
actually standing at it good
understand the python environment
management through hiking
you ready let's see if we can do it big
clap
so
it
changes so
what's the problem we are trying to
solve and what's about hiking with
python environments
first problem we have
among many is how many tools you can use
to actually set up a python environment
and set up any project you want so if i
talk today about poetry next week you
will come to me say yeah conda does it
why use poetry and then someone else can
tell me i can do it in docker or just
install it on your system and it will
just work and we know that every few
weeks or months we could have even yet
another tool and of course there's an
xkcd joke about it so we have 14
standards why not do one which is
universal and we'll solve our problems
now we have 15 of them and that's
exactly what happens with python system
so how can we look at the problem in a
way not from the tools perspective but
ask ourselves the question what do we
actually need when we have it maybe in a
year we could have one tool which can do
all
sorts all of it at once but
what should we ask ourselves
and let's go for a hike as an analogy so
we're going on a hike work-life balance
you've been in covered eating a lot so
it's a good idea the first thing you try
to do is
let's prepare my backpack so you get
your green backpack and you have your
very essential stuff knife
food boots hiking sticks everything is
good you go on a hike it was outstanding
hike you get to this view you just love
it
and then you get another idea well
that's a good lake
what about canoeing
that's also a nice adventure so you take
the same backpack you get your fishing
gear your diving gear your swimsuit and
your apple you try to go there but
apparently your fishing gear and your
diving gear doesn't fit together in the
same backpack so you say well i can just
buy a new backpack it will just fit
everything well and you go on this
hiking trip it's amazing on this
canoeing trip it's amazing you go into
this environment and you see campers and
you
think to yourself well camping is nice
so let's do the same for camping and you
get your blue
backpack it doesn't fit the book and the
first aid kit and say wait a second i
can use a hiking backpack that's a good
idea
but the hiking backpack doesn't fit the
knife also with first aid kit so you end
up buying yet another backpack and now
you have one backpack per adventure
which is nice but you start forgetting
which one to use when and how your tools
are going
so what do you do
amazing idea take all your backpacks
with you on every adventure
that's the only solution right
so you do this and then you figure out
okay there should be a better solution
to it and what you think to yourself is
what if i can hire someone to manage my
backpacks
i have enough money i could do it maybe
so let's hire someone and you should
tell this person exactly what you need
and what you will tell them is all your
interests swimming camping canoeing
hiking and everything you need all the
tools you could possibly need
where to buy those tools how much money
you have to buy the tools and the goal
of your trips
and then
you would be relaxed amazing all you
have to consider is actually going on
the specific trip
but you're still angry because i still
didn't tell you anything about python
environments and that's the next point
so if you look at the problem that we
have is having a hiking trip you need a
specific kind of backpacks to get your
specific tools your assistant will get
those tools from specific shops and
prepare your backpack for you for this
specific adventure now in python we have
a specific project and you have a
specific python environment you need
with a specific version of a python
environment which is the color of the
backpack you have the tools which are
the libraries this assistant is actually
your python environment or package
management and the shops are
repositories where you could get those
tools from now which questions do you
ask yourself in this case is
what is your trip about higher level
questions
which tools do you need to succeed who
is preparing your backpack your tools
and where do i even find those tools so
one example is a rest api serving a
python model super easy that's actually
your adventure then you say i need fast
api i need pytorch where do i get them
fast api anywhere pythos from original
repository those are your tools then you
say which backpack do i need that's
exactly python and then you choose 3.9.4
that's your backpack you you say to
yourself well pi am can buy backpacks
for me so why not use pi amp in this
case and then you say poetry can just
manage my tools and put them in this
backpack so why not use poetry in this
case and you end up having a fairly good
environment because you ask the right
questions you could replace poetry with
another tool but as soon as as long as
you're asking the correct questions you
will choose the correct tool for the job
and hopefully you don't end up like this
with so many tools and installations of
python environment that you don't even
know what you're working on
so to try to solve this problem
even further just yesterday i created an
empty repository which i will post some
code to it the link to it is python y
because that's exactly your frustration
when you look at it and what i'm trying
to do is to have some template
repository where we could just all work
on it maybe have make files poetry
docker everything that could possibly be
what is a minimum viable product or just
working and then we can contribute that
community ask the correct questions and
not create the 15 standard please
thank you
thank you very much john mark right let
me look at my magic list yan do we have
a yan i didn't have a last name there we
go
good and please you are the canonical
yen um lovely if you'd like to set
yourself up on the podium yan
is going to be understanding conda in
five minutes
which is ridiculous that is a complex
tool yes you have five minutes let's see
how that's going to i can't even resolve
dependencies
you should use
mamba either way he's going to try and
that is what we that is what we
encourage here at pi day to london
lovely are you all
ready let's see i mean
there we go cool right big clap
awesome i think this is a very nice
transition from the previous
presentation so understanding content
five minutes let's see how it goes
um
first question here who's using conda
please raise your hand
it's about
more than half maybe half
so
i think the reason this presentation is
important is because i made a friend at
this presentation at this conference and
his name is martin martin are you here
maybe raise your hand if you're here
he's in here well you should be careful
who you call friends these days
uh anyways like we were talking about
konda and he said that he tried conda he
got confused
and he ended up using virtual enfant pip
instead because it just seemed more
straightforward and
i want to show you guys that maybe you
should try conda and also demystified a
bit from the past experience that i've
had with it
so what is conda conda much like pip is
a package manager
like in in comparison to pip however it
is language agnostic so you cannot only
install python packages
like scikit-learn but also c libraries
like ffmpeg or javascript stuff like
prettier and you install all of them
through the same interface which i find
personally very nice
it is also cross-platform so you can
build specific packages depending on
whether your user is installing them on
linux windows
m1 whatever like it doesn't matter you
can be very specific about it
it has a very sophisticated package
dependency resolver so
if you have a difficult environment a
complex environment with many
dependencies it figures figures out what
are the right versions for you to use
and also i think this is very important
it has relatively carefully curated
packages
which means you have a better protection
against like name squatting attacks or
typo squatting attacks what i mean by
that is
for example if we compare with pipey the
python packaging index somebody last
year
pushed i think within a week or
something 3500 empty repositories to pip
and there's nothing uh
like stopping you from doing that as
well and then you could technically
insert malicious code into pipey and
people might install it accidentally and
bad things happen
so the next thing i want to talk about
is like there's always like
a lot of confusion about all these
different words like i always hear
things like i installed package packages
with anaconda and no you don't install
them with anaconda but like there's a
reason like i can understand why this is
confusing so i wanted to give a bit of
like definitions here so you might have
heard of mamba mamba is pretty much like
conda it's a package manager it's just a
faster somewhat drop-in replacement for
conda so usually you should probably
prefer mumba over conda
anaconda is a company they're selling or
they're giving away free swag outside so
you should probably have heard of them
they do data science and open source
stuff they are the creators of the
contact package manager and they also
maintain a contact channel which is
basically a container that contains
conda packages called anaconda which has
the same name
and since it's a bit difficult to
contribute to that channel there's also
conda forge which is community managed
it's a channel that any of you could
technically add their packages to
through a well-defined review process
and
then everybody else would be able to use
it
you can install conda and mamba for
example through this link this is what i
would call the recommended approach
which installs miniforge which gives you
mamba and condaforge basically as the
source for installing packages
how do you find conduct packages well
there's different ways of doing that you
can use the terminal you can like type
mumba search and then the name or like
some sort of pattern of what you're
looking for
you can also look on this website here
where i think it's here there we go
okay this is working so it doesn't
matter so that's basically a website
where you can search for things and
keep in mind that not every package that
you see on pipey exists on conda forge
and also not all of them have the same
name for example there's a package
called duckdb on pipey but on condaforge
it's called python.db again because
condaforge is not specific to any
language so different names
conduct packages are essentially just
compressed directories that contain
files so basically if you look into a
contact package it's just a bunch of
stuff that when you install it it gets
copied into the right place in your
system
you can even build contact packages
fairly easily it's essentially just a
yaml file that contains stuff like how
do you build a package and what it
depends on like and this can be
templated using a tool called grayscale
you can even like push very easily to
condaforge by opening a pull request in
this staged recipes repository adding
the yaml file you've just templated with
grayscale pushing it waiting for
approval merging it and already it's
there
all of these things if you have more
than five minutes you can
look into these resources all of this is
actually well documented and much less
magic than you might think and i hope
this was enough for you to at least
consider giving conda and the conda
ecosystem a try thank you
thank you very much jan that was exactly
as built that was pretty good well done
for squeeze that all in uh juan louise
yes uh you're next so if you'd like to
come up and get yourself plugged in
uh
louise is going to talk about this is
not the pandas oh hello
health and safety trip hazards
um this is not the pandas logo
so
good
is this the hdmi
there you go
ready to go yep
big clap
pandas
lovely animals
a little bit clumsy though
they do funny stuff
eat bamboo
and they give a knife to a python
library so you might have heard of this
little python library called pandas that
we usually import as pd
but you might not know that pandas has a
logo
and this logo has been there since
october 2019 which i call uh year zero
of civilization
and but it's there it was responsible by
indeed so thank you very much indeed for
giving us a decent logo
and when i say decent logo i mean
i don't want to
bash anyone's
design skills but every time i look at
this
i think
this more or less okay so when you start
learning pandas you say okay i'm going
to use my search engine of choice which
in my case is not google by the way
and look for some
tutorials documentation information and
things like that and then there's
this thing creeping in
you see
and
the thing is that when you see this you
cannot unsee it anymore and it's
everywhere so for example i found this
other
page that also has this weird
pandas logos mostly
and i also found this other version that
didn't even bother removing like the
white
lines of the background
and this other one removed the ice which
is super
crazy i don't know
um
sorry
and pandas are not bears but don't spoil
my talk please
so you see this pandas logo keeps coming
up over and over again even though like
we're still wondering whether pandas are
bears or not
apparently i just learned while
preparing this talk that pandas comes
from the chinese word for bear
so maybe they are birth maybe they're
not i have no idea but clearly that was
not a pandas
and so
why why is this happening and
you see
there's this little town in southern
europe called madrid
that has this statue in the central
square called el soyal madrono
and i don't know weird three that i
don't know how it's called in english
and
actually jake bunderplas
a
very famous person in the community
noticed in 2016
that this is not the pandas logo it's
the python madrid logo and if you go to
the python madrid website you see very
clearly that the logo is there because
it's inspired in the statue and i should
know because i was the one making it
some years ago and
so you see after all this confusion we
didn't want to add any more uh stuff to
the mix so
when i designed the pi data madrid
banner i didn't complicate myself like
adding bears or symbols or things like
that just in case it ends up in some
weird place that it shouldn't be
and so now i have a proposal for you
follow me on twitter i'm juan luis back
on twitter send me the most cursed
version of the fake pandas logo that you
can find and maybe come to pydata madrid
to give a talk thank you
thank you very much one right next up
mark
mark madsen there we go there we go
there's mark if you'd like to get
yourself plugged in
right
mark will be talking about pi script
and panel or introduction to the team
yeah lovely can you hear me
yeah crazy one
thanks
so how do i get something on the screen
okay thanks you ready yeah good
hi there thanks for taking the time i
figured out i would just look at the
schedule of pi daily london to see
what's in it for me so i analyzed
analyzed it a bit and i could see my
favorite things are missing
there's nothing about database data
exploration data apps or deployment so
that's what i'll be talking about
so
please listen along i'll be talking a
little bit about my favorite data
framework which is a panel and something
about pi script which is the new thing
so we started this morning with a
keynote
and sylvain said something about the
next 10 million users of python
would be coming from jupiter light
and peter wang he actually believes
probably that the next 10 million users
are coming from pi script so i guess
they will be talking a little bit
together
so
my name is mark i work for a company
called ersten and we do a lot of data
exploration and data visualization and
data tools so that's why i'm interested
in the topic
so erster
builds and operates wind farms i provide
analytics for traders that asked us so
we built a lot of apps like this using
panel
and
i also
try to share a little bit about panels
so this is my website awesomepanel.org i
also have a sister site called
awesomestreamlit.org so you might know
that one as well
so
panel is a data
framework
and just as the rest of python it runs
on your laptop it runs on servers but if
you want to share it easily
it's difficult right you need a team of
skilled experts to put it up somewhere
so that's why
pi script is coming into the
into the picture also earlier today i
heard a great and inspiring talk from
tambie about piradite how that actually
solves security and privacy issues
around data of children in
in uk so there are a lot of use cases
for having python in the in the browser
um so let me go back this was the
schedule of pi data
so this is a panel and i've already
talked a little bit about it that is
probably the most powerful data
framework in python for example
we heard earlier i think it was
yesterday about desk right if you want
to visualize big data you use data
shader and data shader is in the same
ecosystem as panel so it really has a
place in there
[Music]
so this is just a simple application i
built this morning
and right then i asked my guys to put it
up there on the server and no i did not
because this is in fact a pi script
powered up as well so what i did was i
went to a github instead
right so all
i did to deploy this application powered
by pi script is i went to github made a
new repository went to the settings
right
and then i went to the pages set it up
as a github pages
and
that's actually it and then i have a
deployment right
so that's
really really easy i don't know how many
has tried to like deploy
web applications based on python right
it it takes time
to get up and running and so on so pi
script is really easy in that sense
but that's a long way
because when i started out
i really wanted to make
this word cloud here interactive i
wanted to be able to change the
background color or maybe the fonts or
whatever but the problem here is that
the word cloud package itself has c
bindings
and they cannot run in the browser yet
so this is something that python has to
solve over time
regarding their packages getting them
compiled to wesson
furthermore a lot of the packages are
really really big so python has to start
thinking about minimizing the package
size sizes
for running in the browser
also
if you think about it you want to work
with data
in the browser you cannot just you pd.c
csv it doesn't work so all of our
infrastructure all of our python pages
all the way we think we have to start
preparing it for the browser
so we need to say if
so
if pyrodite insisted module for example
then we are in the browser and how do we
want to
react to that and
and give
things to our users
so what can we get especially for panel
that i'm interested in so besides
deployment we can get speed ups and
probably there's a talk about data
visualization tomorrow so one of the
things we want is we want our
applications to be really really snappy
and the problem with python right is it
runs on a server and then there's a
front end and you have to send data back
and forth you could not achieve like
speed ups like this if it was a server
client based architecture here we can
write get really a speed sub speedups
the same with like streaming
applications this has been running all
day and it's just streaming there
and it's python in the background
[Music]
so to summarize
i've been able to uh yeah this morning
build a small panel app
deployed by a pi script and
for me that's really really nice
and if you want to connect you can find
my details
at the awesomepanel.org
so and please come and talk if you're
interested in hearing more about this
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much mark right
alex
um
yeah brilliant good
uh lovely and alex you want to get
yourself plugged in
um alex we're talking about
correlation at scale yeah
yeah good clap
thank you
thank you
so yeah i want to add some algorithmics
here pretty simple i will skip most of
the slides and try to make it faster uh
so at another we are doing autonomous
business monitoring and anomaly
detection
and we are doing at the large scale
uh how large uh we are working with
almost like half of billion of metrics
and it's much more in data points if you
think about it like one minute roll of
metric is uh sends at least 1 000 data
points daily
and
so having 2 millions of
real-time anomalies we are reducing this
number by two orders of magnitude uh
using correlation this is the process i
wanted to discuss with you
uh
customers not interesting
so i will explain in a few words how the
system works uh so we are running we are
receiving data from the customers in
multiple ways like database connections
api calls
so on for each metric we are creating
the baseline and the deviation from the
baseline is actually done normally
multiple anomalies correlated to
[Music]
anomaly groups and we're sending alert
to the customer and receiving feedback
back from the customer on the about the
normal equality about the earthquake
um
so here you can see like one metric the
line is number of active users for
example and the shaded area is the
baseline so after a few periods of time
the baseline becomes like better and
better and after a few weeks you can see
it's almost
like fits perfectly the metric itself
and the second example you can see the
deviation from the norm which is
discovered as anomaly in the system
so why do we need the correlation at all
so building the
a first of all we want to build the root
cause analysis we don't want to analyze
each metric separately each anomaly
separately but some correlation group
and understand the causality
and
probably we don't want to send all the
anomalies we found to the customers
because it can be like tens of thousands
of anomalies in the system
so this is the example for the first
reason
we found like two separate anomalies one
normally about the
api errors and in our anomaly is about
the
sale so payment success rate uh so we
want to understand we want one to
understand the
the
reason and say okay the api is not
working which is why the sales drop
right
uh and here it's it's in our example
like for some real customer we've
working with four million metrics you
can have like tens of thousands of
anomalies daily and
you don't want you want to send just
probably tens of alerts daily
uh so i wanted to explain about the
algorithmics we are using we are using
um
a few correlation algorithms one of them
is the
graph correlation which is pretty simple
it's more like a regex
and
some analysis of the data
name correlation and abnormal
correlation
uh so the graph correlation is as i said
is mostly regex and some understanding
about the data like data coming from the
same data source is probably a
correlated if you have anomaly in the
table probably all the group buys will
be affected by the same anomaly uh right
the downside is obviously you know if
you have a problem and trying to solve
it with regex now we have two problems
and this is exactly the way it works in
production
uh name correlation is uh more about
metadata like we are trying it's tfidfs
algorithm with soft penalty on
penalty on
token usage so if token is overused
we'll give some penalty for this token
again it works fine but you will need to
you need to have like
well-defined names of metrics in your
system it's not not always the case
uh the abnormal combination is
[Music]
more interesting um
because it actually
checks the
behavior of the metric over time
so i will skip to solution the solutions
the lsh basically so instead of checking
the actual vectors of the matrix we're
checking the signatures
and
this is more or less how this h works
we're just trying to find the signature
for each for each vector in the system
and once we need to find the correlated
vector we are checking only the related
correlation bucket right only the bucket
having the same lsh signature on the
system
um
skip skip skip
so basically this is the
uh this is how the again
very complexity is good better when
landing when index and brute force
obviously about log n
uh
yeah the usage is interesting because at
the end of the process you have some
bucket of uh signatures uh you can check
and you are checking only the
only the vectors having the same
signature at least at one position and
then actually checking the uh
no
distance the actual distance
between vectors so in this example i'm
checking only the
on the distance only for four vectors
like to find two matching vectors you
can take it as like a one hundred
percent recall with fifty percent uh
um yeah
a
pipeline uh okay this like the full
architecture look like so we have some
offline process for lsh and vectors
calculation the online process for
grouping and actually correlation graph
and the online
the online process to find all the
anomalies and send it to the kafka
stream of
online grouping
a okay
i think yeah that's all thank you
thank you very much i am now looking for
a raphael
yay there we go right so rafael is going
to talk to us about taming python
environments with pip conda and mamba
this is the third in our series
of package relevant talks i expect you
all to be experts
it might come up in the quiz you never
know this is all useful stuff
so i
know there we go that's looking good
ready to go yeah lovely big clap
everyone thank you
hope you're excited to hear more about
conda environments
i mean uh such a pain that three people
have to come here to talk about it
just uh
this is universe
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show you
the solution so listen carefully so uh
yeah just just
have you thinking like how much time
have you spent packing your backpack
changing your backpack and etc in your
life in your career
uh whatever the answer is i bet it's too
much
so
i'm to go through kind of my thinking my
workflow on this
mostly using conda and pip
and a bit of mamba as well so uh just
i'll go over the definitions but i think
you're all experts by now we have the
traditional pip virtual env
for scientific computing
uh
the go to tool is often anaconda which
offers a curated list of packages in the
conda
package manager and environment manager
and uh there's also mamba which is a bit
less known but it's basically a
re-implementation of conda that's much
faster to run
and which one should you choose so
looking kind of at
google trends data as a proxy for
popularity
we kind of see that it doesn't seem that
one technology is overtaking the other
dramatically but both kind of have found
their niche and
do what they do and have their
core users that like their tools so
they're not really in competition
it's more of when should you use which
tool
so
[Music]
virtual end is
the de facto
standard for python packages it's
lightweight but
reproducibility as i as it was said
before is a bit difficult and there's no
dependency graph optimization but for
anything lightweight
it works really well and it has worked
for a long time
then
conda is
it can optimize dependency graphs
and it can manage like multiple versions
of python and
in python binaries as it was already
said
but you need to kind of have the
software pre-installed so there's a bit
more preparation and sometimes it can be
extremely slow and that's basically why
uh it was there's mamba that was also
created which
works much faster but is maybe less
widely adopted
so um
how do i work with all these tools which
actually work pretty well together
so for anything very simple where i
don't really care about
reproducibility or i don't have a lot of
dependencies just pip vm that's the go
to solution and then
conda and mamba combination um
if i want something a bit more
complicated
so the
setup
you usually need to have anaconda
installed as i said so one simple way is
to do it through mini conda which is
lightweight downloads very quickly
uh it's always good to update conda
because they do a lot of
updates and you you can use the latest
version
and then uh
the key to kind of combining
mamba to
conda is to download this conda lib
mamba solver
and it's actually the product of
a collaboration between the conda people
and the mamba people to bring the
speed and the functionalities of the
mamba solver into
conda it's still
experimental but for
yeah everything i've done up to now i
have i didn't have any any issues on
that
there's actually a good uh blog article
that's linked here uh explaining what
what this is
and yeah so once you have that set up
you can just create your
environment with a conduct create and
just give in all the dependencies that
you're interested in having you can also
give version numbers if you want that
and you can really be crazy about it and
just throw in
whatever you want and let
the conda and member server kind of
figure it out
and that's where yeah it used to be
quite slow
and with this solver libmumba it's much
faster now
and then once you in created the
environment you can install new
conda
packages you can install additional pip
patches that are going to be installed
in your library and you can even install
the local
your local code in editable mode
and when you're ready to kind of share
your code in your environment you can do
a conda and export and save that into
the environments file and it's going to
really put all the configurations that
you need to reproduce it later and
anybody using your code
or developing it can create a new
environment with passing this file that
you've created and then it's really a
deterministic recreation with the pip
including the peep
package libraries that you added so
it's this environment.yaml it's going to
be a very
large
file with a lot of lines and all the the
version numbers etc but it's actually
okay because that that's what gives the
the reproducibility
and it's a good practice to just add
that to your project on git so every
developer can just use it
yeah just a quick notice that
since march 2022
the
terms of services of anaconda changed
and for commercial use you need a
license so just something you should
know if it applies to you just go see on
their website or talk to the people that
are waiting outside
thank you very much raphael
right james you're up as our last
lighting speaker
james is to talk on coherent but not
consistent
which incidentally is my wife's pet name
for me
there you go so
she doesn't seem to like you very much
yes
the cackle from the west um shall you
tell them what's coming up right after
we're done here no i'm gonna go
afterwards mate i'm looking forward to
this
okay let's get this going on
plug that in
plug that in
james which window management system are
you currently using on your desktop
that's unfair
is it a tiling window manager oh it
absolutely is
let's get this just so leaked
well that's why they shouldn't listen to
anything i have to say
yep
and we'll get this
going yep no it's coming coming just
give it a second
there we go
let's move that here
pop that up there oh there we go there
we go you ready
yeah lovely big clap everyone
this is coherent not consistent my name
is james powell we're at pi day to
london it's saturday june 18 2022
one important note before i start this
talk i put this together in about 15
minutes please do not take this talk
seriously i think pandas is a fantastic
tool it is coherent in its design but it
is not particularly consistent one other
disclaimer do not listen to anything i
have to say because this is actually how
i import pandas in my code i say from
panda's import data frame i clearly have
no idea what i'm doing
now i'll tell you what this talk is not
about this talk is not about things like
in-place equals true which they're
getting rid of anyway because it doesn't
really do what you think it does this
talk is not about the copy equals true
or false parameter that sometimes
appears to actually work the way you
want and tell pandas to make or not make
a copy and then other times seems to not
work the way you want and actually still
make a copy anyway so copy equals false
doesn't actually not copy something
because if you really think about why
this works the way it does it kind of
makes sense
this talk is not about
why you have to reset index all the time
because you probably shouldn't be
resetting index all the time because
that's not what panda is about panda is
about index data if you're resetting
index you're not really using pandas for
what it's used for
it's also not about why the pandas
documentation seems to insist that
pandas is a two-dimensional data
structure it's not the panda's
documentation is wrong a panda's data
frame is like indexed one-dimensional
data you should be thinking in terms of
one-dimensional data when using pandas
but that's not what we're here to talk
about
this talk is also not about why there
seem to be so many different ways to
backfill stuff like you can b fill
or you can backfill or you can fill n a
b fill because i understand that pandas
is a convenience tool and so that's why
for example fill in a method equals f
fill is the same thing as df.pad i guess
you know you need to have a lot of
different ways to say things like for
example you ever noticed that you have
skew and kurtosis and curt those extra
couple of letters when you're computing
a kurtosis really seem to impact our
work
now this is more about i don't know why
in the pandas api when you have a series
object and you want to apply an
operation to every single element which
you probably shouldn't do but you can do
anyway you have to use dot apply but if
you try that on an index the dot apply
method doesn't actually exist you have
to use index.map why do they change the
names here doesn't make any sense to me
of course
you probably don't care about this next
one which is why is it that i can set an
index to set the row index but i can't
do a set index with axis equals column
to move a row of this up into the column
index that doesn't seem to make any
sense to me it seems like should people
do both of them because that's not
consistent with set access which is
largely doing the same thing that also
takes an access parameter so why doesn't
set index have an access parameter it
seems like that would be the consistent
operation and also why is it that rename
axis like set axis has an access
parameter but set index doesn't and by
the way does anybody here actually
remember on the first try which one they
want when they want to set index reset
index set axis
set rename access or you just try them
in a row and then finally you say i
think the one i wanted is rename here's
the other thing notice here i have to
use a string because you can't rename
axis with anything that's not a string
even though you can actually name the
the
elements of your index or you can name
your index itself something that's not a
string that's completely valid but the
rename axis doesn't allow you to do that
and why is it that rename access has an
index equals and a columns equals
keyword argument that doesn't seem to
exist anywhere else throughout the api i
guess people when they rename index
really want to make it shorthand whether
they're doing that on the axis of the
columns speaking of bizarre keyword
arguments what the heck is going on with
melt var underscore name value
underscore name that convention doesn't
seem to be in use anywhere else
additionally am i the only one who seems
to care about when you're trying to
assign a new column into your data frame
you can assign it using keyword
arguments but and you can even unpack a
dictionary to do the same thing but you
can't pass just a dictionary so that you
can have say columns which don't have
string names that's extremely useful
non-string named columns and yet that's
not valid and instead what i have to do
is some contortion using join i have to
join a series that happens to be named
something because it is completely valid
to have a column that does not have a
string name and in fact it's quite
useful
now
sometimes i have two data frames and i
want to join them together and please
don't tell me join on something you
should join on the index that's what
it's for but why do i have an l suffix
and an r suffix parameter that doesn't
appear anywhere else in the api
especially since on merge it's called
suffixes
and why do i have this in the first
place what i really should have is
multi-index columns which by the way are
very useful so in fact if i ever want to
really do this i have to do a pipe set
axis combination so that i can get a
data frame that has multi-index columns
so i can unambiguously refer to the
original columns of the original
structure and you might look at that and
say why on earth did you need those
contortions in the first place well part
of it's because set axis unlike anything
else doesn't take a lambda and you can
see it's not because it's ambiguous it's
just because they decided not to do that
it's just missing even though everything
else seems to take a lambda as a
particular argument so you have to use
pipe and additionally
when you have a multi-index you can drop
a level from a multi-index but you can't
add a level to a multi-index i don't
know why not it seems like you
oftentimes want to just add a level in
because that's what you're doing when
you're joining you add a level to the
column multi-index and then you join
them together and then you can
unambiguously refer to which column came
from which of the two starting
structures and you probably don't care
about any of that because you say i
don't care about pandas and the column
names the data and the modeling i just
care about my computations i care about
my data and i care about taking a data
frame and doing a df.describe and sure
they may be getting rid of df.describe
at some point but note why on earth is
this a series with a d type float
because that makes the count a floating
point number what on earth does it mean
to have a floating point count you can't
have 3.5 of something in a count this
should be a data frame where there's one
row and each of these are columns so
that you can have the appropriate d type
on these this is a mistake and i guess
it's maybe just a convenience
but this even affects us in our lives
because if we happen to have a data
frame with three distinct values in it
and we do a very common operation like a
group by on this you can see oh no i
lost one of the distinct values because
it upcasted through float even those of
the original integer values and even
though it looks like it's actually
keeping these integer values look it
used to be two three and four and now
it's two four and two i lost data on an
operation that shouldn't have lost data
at all and it's worse if i unstack it
but that kind of makes sense if i
unstack it because it turns into a nand
so that it can represent the missing
data and if i unstack and fill now
that's not going to do anything much
better but if i unstack with a fill
value it looks like it preserved these
being integer values but it didn't it
passed through float64 anyway so it lost
my information in the first place and if
you say well there's not enough
information available to pandas in order
to do that you should use something like
pivot table which provides enough
information for the pandas api to provo
prevent the loss of this data well it
still loses this data because i still
see there's only two distinct values
here not three distinct values i've lost
information as a consequence of an
operation which shouldn't have lost
information
but in the end
i kind of like pandas it's a useful tool
it's got a coherent api it's designed
around index and indexed alignment
operations it's not particularly
consistent there's a lot of things that
i have to memorize and fast iteration is
what helps me in this case because when
i know that i can re-order underscore
levels and i cannot remember if it's
swap underscore level no it's not swap
underscore levels no it's not swap level
no plural no underscore completely
inconsistent with reorder underscore
levels it doesn't really matter because
i can iterate fast enough and the tool
itself is quite useful in my work thank
you so much
ah
i kind of felt like we gave you a nice
free bit of catharsis there that felt
that felt good right it was good to get
it out
we all love pandas you know i mean
that's what the rebels for right is for
guessing at what the method names are
perfect right well thank you ever so
much that draws the conclusion of our
lightning talks but of course brings us
on to the next item of our agenda which
of course is the social so of course
after uh we are all finished here we are
all gonna go out into the expo area
you're very welcome uh to go back to
wherever you've come from and crash out
if you've had enough for today but if
you would like to keep the party going
uh hop works is sponsoring our social
event this evening so they have a number
of branded beer which they've created
they still do not make beer but they do
have hops in the title so i guess they
felt obliged to start a brewery
just for the conference um but yes they
are basically sponsoring it until it
goes dry in which case then you'll have
to use your hard earned dinero uh to buy
the rest of it uh and then of course we
will be having the pub quiz which will
be hosted uh by our uh wonderful james
powell afterwards the pub quiz is don't
don't use don't use this code code pub
quiz
um
i don't know the title james what's
title of the pop quiz
is the pub case what happens
what happens with the pub quiz well the
format of pub quiz uh should be etched
in the brains of every uh person in this
room about how pop quiz works uh you
will sit in teams and you will answer
questions which are asked uh the
questions are designed uh to make you
feel like an idiot it's important we
know a lot of you in this room have
obviously been doing software and data
science for a long time and it's quite
right you were taking down a peg and
we're going to ask you questions which
quite frankly no one should be asking
but you are going to be expected to
answer a good score at the pub quiz just
because in case you are used to getting
100 on your tests or have been for your
whole life
is probably about 30 percent if you get
anything above 30 you're cheating um
and i should also i mean the the general
tip is that a lot of things do focus on
the non-focus packages so i do invite
you uh to uh revise the board outside of
all the fiscally sponsored projects at
the non-focus sponsor
uh is there a prize is there a
that's a good point what is the price i
think i'll give a free ticket next year
but also you know you're the best yeah
right so of course bragging rights and
eternal glory which of course is the
most important thing uh but we will also
be giving away a free ticket a free
three-day ticket to the conference next
year so of course yeah there we go that
is a serious prize for you all um
yes and i believe we're at the end of
that thank you ever so much for your
participation uh in the uh talk part of
uh the conference um please do join us
at the social and if you don't uh then
we'll see you all tomorrow for the
second day thank you very much everyone
cheers